Всім привіт! Мене звати Віктор Мелніков.
Я викладач математики школи «Майбутні».
Сьогодні ми з вами будемо
розбирати тему: «Скалярний добуток»
і практикуватися в
розв`язуванні цих задач.
На минулому занятті ми розбирали
різні способи,
як знайти скалярний добуток.
Зокрема, щоб знайти скалярний добуток –
треба перемножити
модулі двох векторів на косинус
кута між ними.
Косинус кута між векторами –
це кут між векторами,
між відрізками, які відтворюють вектори,
якщо сполучити основи векторів.
Це перший варіант.
Другий варіант – це попарно перемножити
координати векторів,
якщо координати вектора А(х1;у1),
а вектора B(х2;у2),
то скалярний добуток можна знайти
за формулою: х1*х2+у1*у2
Перед цим ми можемо знайти косинус кута,
виразивши із першої та другої формули,
прирівнявши і відповідно,
отримавши формулу.
Сьогодні ми з вами будемо практикуватися
в розв`язанні різних задач.
Давайте виберемо першу задачу
і подивимося, що з нею можна зробити.
Ми знаємо, якщо в нас є вектори і формули,
пов`язанні з кутом – це скалярний добуток.
Тобто, можна знайти скалярний добуток,
потім можна знайти косинус кута,
а вже за косинусом визначити,
який там кут.
Давайте це спробуємо зробити.
Спочатку знайдемо
скалярний добуток цих двох векторів,
позначаємо: а, b.
Скалярний добуток можемо знайти
за формулою з координатами.
Тепер підставимо іншу формулу.
Модуль вектора a.
Якщо координати вектора a (3;2),
то його модуль знаходимо за формулою:
корінь квадратний
із 3 у квадраті плюс 2 в квадраті;
3 у квадраті = 9; 2 в квадраті = 4,
√(9+4)=√13
Аналогічно знаходимо модуль вектора b:
4 в квадраті плюс 1 у квадраті,
√(16+1)=√17;
і помножити на косинус кута між ними.
Прирівнявши ці два вирази,
знайдемо косинус.
До речі, 13 на 17 можна помножити,
використовуючи формулу
скороченого множення.
Отже буде 14/√221
Однак, який це буде кут?
Тобто, який такий кут, що його косинус
дорівнює цьому значенню?
Табличку ми у звичайному підручнику
не знайдемо.
Давайте спробуємо оцінити.
По-перше: косинус у нас додатній,
тобто, ми вже знаємо,
що цей кут більший за нуль.
Гострий кут менший 90, більший за нуль
і його косинус додатній.
Ми можемо оцінити: цей кут ближче
до нуля чи до 90 градусів?
Для цього ми можемо написати
під одним коренем.
14 – це корінь із 196, тобто у нас буде
√(196/221)
196/221 ближче до одиниці, ніж до нуля.
Якщо косинус ближче до одиниці,
отже кут ближче до нуля градусів.
Тобто, це, все-таки,
ближче до нуля, ніж до 90.
Ми можемо порівняти його значення косинуса
із косинусом якогось відомого кута.
Ну, наприклад, косинус 30-ти градусів.
дорівнює √3/2
Порівнявши оцей косинус із цим, дізнатися,
як розташовано цей кут
відносно 30 градусів.
Це буде корінь із трьох четвертих.
Я пропоную зробити вам це самостійно,
подивитися, як три четвертих
і сто дев’яноста шість
двісті двадцять перших,
відрізняються між собою.
Відповідно, якщо виявляється,
що косинус оцього кута трішки більше,
ніж оцей косинус,
то якщо косинус більше – це означає,
що значення самого кута
кута буде менше,
використовуючи тригонометричне коло.
Якщо в нас буде більше значення косинуса,
то кут буде менше.
Таким чином, ми можемо приблизно
зорієнтуватися, який це кут, або
ви використовуйте якісь
спеціальні програми для того,
щоб знайти відповідь на подібні задачі.
Давайте зробимо наступну задачу.
Увага на слайд.
Давайте спробуємо «погратися» з рівністю,
яка задана умовою задачі.
Спробуємо перемножити цей вираз.
По-перше, ми з вами вже знаємо,
що якщо в нас вектор
множиться сам на себе,
тобто m на m, це те саме,
що помножити модуль вектора m
на модуль вектора m.
Тобто, ці 2 вирази ми можемо знайти,
знаючи їх модулі.
Враховуючи, що модуль вектора m = 2,
то тут буде 4,
а тут буде мінус 3 помножити на модуль
вектора n в квадраті, тобто на 9.
Виразимо тут скалярний добуток.
Обчислимо це значення.
Ми знаємо, що скалярний добуток
цих двох векторів дорівнює шість,
і ми знаємо їх модулі.
Отже, підставимо нашу формулу
і знайдемо косинус кута.
Оскільки модуль вектора m=2, n=3,
то тут 2 помножити на 3 і на косинус,
дорівнює 6.
Це означає, що косинус альфа
дорівнює один.
Якщо косинус кута дорівнює один,
це означає, що альфа – нуль градусів.
Тобто, кут між векторами m і n
дорівнює нуль градусів.
Давайте розглянемо задачу на доведення.
Треба довести, що чотирикутник
з цими вершинами є прямокутним,
яким чином можна це зробити?
Наприклад, ми можемо спочатку довести,
що взагалі ця фігура є паралелограмом,
а потім вже подумати
як довести, що паралелограм
є прямокутником.
Якщо пробуємо довести, що це паралелограм,
то достатньо довести,
що дві сторони паралельні і рівні,
тоді фігура – паралелограм.
Для цього ми можемо довести
рівність векторів.
Давайте розглянемо
два протилежних вектора, які тут є.
Наприклад: АВ.
Знайдемо його координати. Від координати
В віднімаємо А - отримємо (1;2).
Також вектор DC. Від С
віднімаємо D і також отримаємо (1;2).
Ми бачимо, що це однакові вектори,
якщо вектори однакові,
це означає, що вони рівні за довжиною
і паралельні, колінеарні.
Тобто, ця фігура є паралелограмом.
Чудово, ми довели, що це паралелограм.
Тепер, якимось чином, треба довести,
що це прямокутник.
Давайте спробуємо, наприклад,
використовуючи спочатку скалярний добуток.
Доведемо, що тут косинус 90 градусів,
тобто, косинус між ними – нуль.
Тобто, що вектори, наприклад,
АВ та АD будуть перпендикулярні.
Для цього знайдемо координати вектора АD.
Знаходимо його координати:
від D віднімаємо A (1-3=-2; -1-(-2)=1)
Отже, це координати AD.
Знаючи координати АВ та AD, знайдемо
скалярний добуток цих двох векторів.
Якщо скалярний добуток векторів нуль –
це означає, що вектори перпендикулярні.
Чудово, отже тут прямий кут.
Якщо це паралелограм,
у якого один кут 90 градусів,
це означає, що всі кути по 90 градусів.
Отже, ця фігура є прямокутником.
Можна піти цим шляхом,
можна іншим – наприклад,
довести (що це паралелограм,
ми вже довели),
що у паралелограма діагоналі однакові,
а якщо так – це також буде прямокутник.
Для цього можна знайти
координати векторів АС і ВD,
а потім подивитися на їх модулі,
на їх довжини.
Взагалі, це теж можна зробити,
спробуйте це зробити самостійно,
а ми підемо далі.
Давайте розглянемо задачу,
яка була на ЗНО.
Ми вже знаємо,
що якщо вектори перпендикулярні,
то це нам підказка:
скалярний добуток векторів має бути нуль.
Якимось чином це можна використати.
Для того, щоб знайти їх скалярний добуток
в нас є дві формули:
або через координати,
або через модулі та косинус кута.
З модулями тут навряд чи щось вийде,
а ось з координатами давайте щось зробимо.
У нас з вами є координати точки А
і не вистачає координати точки В,
щоб записати координати вектора АВ.
Давайте намалюємо систему координат
і пряму Y=2X.
Десь на ній лежить точка В.
Ми не знаємо координати ні по Х, ні по Y.
Втім, давайте позначимо щось як невідому.
Нехай буде Х(нульове).
Тоді ми знаємо абсцису.
Як знайти ординату?
Якщо це пряма Y =2Х, тоді ордината буде
2 помножити на Х(нульове).
Ми знаємо координати точки В,
тепер через невідомі.
Знаємо, за умовою,
що А має координати (-2,0).
Отже ми можемо знайти
координати вектора АВ.
Від В віднімаємо А.
Отримємо АВ (х0+2; 2*х0)
Ми знаємо, що цей вектор
перпендикулярний вектору (4;3).
Таким чином, давайте запишемо,
що скалярний добуток дорівнює нуль,
тому що за умовою вони перпендикулярні.
Цей скалярний добуток має бути нуль.
Розв’яжемо це рівняння.
Перенесемо, добавимо.
Запишемо як десятковий дріб.
Тобто, абсциса точки В дорівнює -0,8.
Якби у нас, за умовою задачі, треба було,
наприклад, знайти ще ординату,
то знаючи Х(нульове), ми помножили б на 2
і знайшли б координати Y точки В.
Все залежить від того, що у вас в задачі.
Давайте розглянемо наступну задачу.
Оскільки це вектори,
то треба це позначити.
Відповідно, якщо у нас переміщення
задається цими векторами,
і за умовою задачі,
треба знайти кут між вектором,
який задає кінцеве положення туриста.
Тобто, починається з табору і закінчується
кінцевою точкою останнього вектора
і східним напрямком, тобто, ось сюди.
По-перше, треба знайти взагалі вектор,
який задає це кінцеве положення.
Оскільки, це вектори (1;4), (4,-1), (1,5),
то вектор, який сполучає
початок і кінець всіх цих трьох векторів,
(а вони виходять один із одного),
можна розглядати, як суму
всіх цих трьох векторів.
Додаємо координати,
отримаємо вектор (6;8).
Тобто, це той вектор,
який сполучає наш початок і кінець.
Треба знайти кут між цим вектором
і східним напрямком.
Тепер як взагалі визначити
цей східний напрямок?
Можна взяти якийсь вектор,
який дивиться суворо на Схід.
Наприклад, такий (на малюнку).
Треба знайти ось цей кут.
Можна використати скалярний
добуток векторів,
давайте це спочатку і зробимо.
Треба помножити ось цей вектор,
назвемо a і b.
Тоді скалярний добуток: 6+0;
з іншого боку – це модуль вектора а,
(корінь із 36+64=100),
а також вектор b (тобто, 1)
і помножити на косинус кута
Таким чином, звідси можна знайти
косинус кута.
Так само, як на самому початку
нашого уроку,
ми можемо щось про цей кут сказати.
0,6 в табличці в нас немає,
але ми можемо зробити якісь висновки.
Наприклад, що цей кут точно гострий,
тому що косинус його додатній,
якщо косинус із 60-ти градусів
дорівнює одна друга, а це 0,6.
Тобто, ось тут 60 градусів
і косинус одна друга,
а це косинус 0,6 – трішки далі.
Це означає, що цей кут буде менше,
ніж 60 градусів.
Порівнюючи такі значення,
робимо якісь висновки про нього.
Це перший спосіб, завдяки якому про
цей кут ми можемо щось сказати.
Інший – можемо розглянути прямокутний
трикутник, якщо це вектор (6;8),
який задає кінцеве положення.
Отже, розглянемо таку систему координат,
її початок буде (0;0).
Якщо це вектор (6;8),
то довжина цього відрізка – 6,
оскільки координата по Х – 6, а це 8.
Із цього прямокутного трикутника
про цей кут можна визначити
якісь тригонометричні функції,
наприклад тангенс.
Тангенс альфа – це відношення
протилежного катета до прилеглого –
вісім шостих або чотири третіх.
Так само, за допомогою тангенса,
можемо також говорити про цей кут.
Тобто, знову ж таки, способи є різні,
ви вибираєте той,
який вам більше подобається
і більше підходить до вашої задачі.
Давайте тепер розв’яжемо задачу
з гелікоптером.
Спочатку пілот виконав
усі вказівки диспетчера
і направився у напрямку зі швидкістю,
що задається вектором (2;4),
але потім помітив,
що він не летить в тому напрямку,
а летить у напрямку (3;2).
Зрозуміло, що йому щось заважає
і це щось – це, наприклад, вітер.
Питання задачі наступні:
В якому напрямку і з
якою швидкістю дме вітер?
На скільки градусів відхилився
гелікоптер від обраного курсу?
Давайте подивимось.
Якщо ми намалюємо вектори (2;4) і (3;2),
то ми розуміємо, що
ось цьому вектору щось заважає,
тобто, вектор, який виходить
з кінця першого в кінець другого.
Тоді цей напрямок, тобто цей вектор,
який ми намалювали – це буде вектор,
який заважає нашому гелікоптеру
летіти в обраному напрямку,
і тоді сума цих двох векторів
дорівнюватиме третьому.
Як знайти оцей вектор, який нам треба?
Для цього ми віднімемо вектори.
Тобто, те, що ми намалювали,
насправді, різниця векторів.
Якщо це іде в напрямку вектора (3;2),
тобто, від цього вектора
віднімається вектор (2;4).
Тобто, оцей зелений вектор,
який відповідає
напрямку руху нашого повітря –
це різниця векторів (3;2) і (2;4).
Тоді це вектор (1;-2).
Тобто, вітер дме у напрямку,
що задовольняє вектор (1;-2).
Один – праворуч, два – вниз.
Тепер з якою швидкістю?
Це буде довжина цього вектора,
тобто, модуль цього вектора.
Це буде √(1(-2)^2)=√5
Відповідь: корінь із п’яти метрів за
секунду (або в інших одиницях виміру).
Друге запитання
задачі: на скільки градусів
відхилився гелікоптер від обраного курсу.
Тобто, нам треба знайти кут
між цими двома векторами.
Це ми сьогодні вже досить багато
розв’язували.
Коли в нас є два вектори
і потрібно знайти кут між ними,
то можна зробити це
за допомогою скалярного добутку.
Давайте так і зробимо. Можемо одразу
згадати формулу.
Підставимо значення.
Скалярний добуток – це буде 6
(2 помножити на 3) і плюс 8.
Тепер модуль кожного вектора:
2 в квадраті плюс 4 в квадраті;
4 плюс 16 – корінь із 20-ти
і на корінь із цього значення;
тобто, 9+4=13.
Отримавши це значення,
можемо трішки спростити.
14 і 2 скорочуємо, зверху отримуємо 7.
Рахуємо. Отримуємо відповідь.
Так само, як і в попередніх задачах,
ми можемо робити якісь висновки
про цей кут, що він гострий,
порівнювати значення з іншими кутами,
щоб знайти в яких межах воно лежить.
Пропоную вам зробити це самостійно.
Давайте перейдемо до наступної задачі.
Давайте подумаємо,
як тут щось можна зробити.
Ми вже розв’язували схожу задачу.
Там, якщо вектори перпендикулярні,
то скалярний добуток дорівнює нуль,
а нам треба знайти координати векторів.
Давайте подивимось.
Якщо коло задовольняє наступному рівнянню
То які координати у центру?
Ми знаємо формулу кола:
(х-а)^2+(y-b)^2= r^2,
де a і b будуть координати центру.
У нашому випадку тут х^2 і y^2.
Отже, координатами центру
будуть точка О(0;0).
Точка М має координати
Х(нульове); Y(нульове).
Пропоную спочатку виразити
Х(нульове) через Y(нульове)
або навпаки, щоб у нас була
лише одна змінна,
і рівняння ми розв’язували
тільки відносно однієї змінної.
Для цього використовуємо оцю нашу рівність
і для цього виразимо Х(нульове).
Давайте Х в квадраті спочатку.
Як отримати Х? можна взяти корінь,
але якщо ми просто візьмемо корінь,
то ми не можемо записати,
що тут Х=корінь з 80-y в квадраті.
Ми можемо записати наступне
(увага на дошку):
За нашою умовою нам відомо,
що Х(нульове) менше, ніж нуль.
Тобто, ось тут від’ємне число.
Розкриваючи модуль,
ми отримаємо наступне (увага на дошку).
Тоді з цієї рівності виразимо Х -
помножимо на мінус 11
і отримаємо х=-√(80-у^2)
Таким чином, давайте позначимо
ординату точки М,
як Y(нульове) – невідома змінна.
Тоді X(нульове), за цією формулою, можемо
записати наступним чином (увага на дошку):
Тоді, ми знаємо координати вектора а,
який перпендикулярний вектору ОМ.
Вектор ОМ має такі самі координати,
як точка М, тому що координати О(0;0).
Тобто, М просто переписуємо.
Ми знаємо координати вектора а (-2;1),
і ми знаємо, що ці
два вектори – перпендикулярні.
Запишемо, що їх скалярний добуток
дорівнює нуль.
Перемножаємо
Розв’язуємо рівняння. Ірраціонально.
Переносимо Y(нульове).
Одразу помічаємо одну річ,
що якщо зліва у нас з вами корінь,
а справа – мінус Y(нульове),
то мінус Y(нульове) має бути
більше або дорівнювати нулю.
Тобто Y(нульове) –
менше або дорівнює нулю.
Це нам треба далі,
щоб знайти правильні корені.
Підносимо до квадрату,
не забуваємо про двійку (увага на дошку):
Розкриваємо дужки і розв’язуємо
це рівняння.
Можемо вже шукати Y-ки.
Щоб це зручніше зробити –
помножимо на 2 і чисельник, і знаменник.
Отже, Y(нульове) у квадраті дорівнює 64.
Взагалі, таке рівняння має два корені –
це 8; -8.
Ми пам’ятаємо, що ось тут ми записали,
що Y(нульове) має бути
менше або дорівнювати нулю,
тобто Y(нульове), враховуючи цю умову,
у нас буде мінус вісім.
Тоді, за умовою задачі,
нам необхідно знайти абсцису точки а.
Тобто, оцей вираз. Знаючи Y(нульове),
ми знайдемо це значення.
Отже, відповідь на умову задачі
буде: мінус чотири. Абсциса точки М = -4.
Давайте розглянемо більш складну задачу.
Давайте намалюємо.
За умовою задачі у нас є трикутник ABC,
і за умовою задачі кут С = 90 градусів.
Одна сторона дорівнює 1, інша = 2.
Нам треба довести, що медіани АК
і медіана СМ – перпендикулярні.
Ну, напевно, якщо у нас тема: «Вектори»,
то потрібно їх якось застосувати,
але якщо ми просто
подивимось на цю задачу,
то помітимо, що нічого про ці вектори
не знаємо.
Ми не знаємо ні їх довжини,
ні їх координати.
Ми нічого не знаємо.
Тому просто так, мабуть, буде важко,
а з цієї думки можна прийти
до наступної ідеї.
Що якщо ми намалюємо координатну площину
і розташуємо точки АСВ
в цій координатній площині так,
щоб вийшов наш трикутник.
Тоді точку С ми позначимо
координатою (0;0), щоб вона в нас була.
Тут якраз кут 90 градусів.
Тоді точки А і В будуть відповідно
на осях Х і Y.
Добре, тоді давайте позначимо точку А.
Нехай, буде ось тут,
тоді АС у нас, за умовою – довжина 1.
Отже, цей відрізок 1.
Отже, координати (1;0).
Тоді координати точки В, оскільки СВ=2 см,
то буде ось тут.
По Х=0, по Y=2.
Той трикутник, який ми зараз намалювали
в прямокутній системі координат,
він буде повністю
збігатися з нашою умовою.
У нас є прямокутний трикутник,
у якого є довжина 1 і є довжина 2,
та нам треба з ним працювати.
Чому це краще?
Тому що якщо ми зараз
намалюємо медіану СМ,
ми вже, якимось чином,
можемо знайти координати цього вектора СМ,
і так само з вектором АК,
а знаючи координати векторів АК,
ми можемо знайти їх скалярний добуток,
показати, що він дорівнює нулю,
і тоді вони будуть перпендикулярні.
Для того, щоб знайти координати вектора,
треба знати координати точок М і К.
Для цього нам треба пригадати,
як ми знаходимо.
Точка М – це середина відрізка АВ.
Як можна знайти середину відрізка,
якщо ми знаємо координати кінців?
По Х = (0+1):2 оскільки
формула -  (х1+х2)/2, і це дорівнює 1/2
те саме з координатами по Y:
По Y: (2+0)/2=1
Отже, координати точки М (1/2;1)
Точка К: По Х – все те саме
((0+0)/2=0), по Y теж ((2+0)/2=1).
Отже, координати точки К(0; 1).
Тепер шукаємо вектори.
Від М віднімаємо С, буде те саме,
що координати точки А – (1/2;1)
Вектор АК(0-1=-1; 1-0=1).
Ми знайшли координати векторів,
давайте знайдемо
скалярний добуток цих векторів.
Перемножуємо відповідні координати
і сумуємо.
У нас виходить відповідь 1/2.
Це означає, що ці вектори
не перпендикулярні,
вони мають якийсь гострий кут між собою,
тому що їх скалярний добуток
більший ніж нуль.
Це означає, що твердження в умові задачі
ми спростували.
Ці дві медіани неперпендикулярні.
Сьогодні ми практикувалися
в розв’язуванні різних задач
на застосування
скалярного добутку векторів.
Давайте трошки пригадаємо.
Щоб знайти кут між векторами,
треба сполучити два вектори так,
щоб вони виходили з однієї точки,
тоді кут між відрізками цих векторів
і буде кутом між цими векторами.
Щоб знайти скалярний добуток,
можна використати два підходи:
або за допомогою формули, або за допомогою
формули з модулями
і косинусом кута між ними.
Коли ми знаходимо скалярний добуток
векторів – за його скалярним добутком
ми можемо визначити цей кут,
ми можемо сказати чи цей кут гострий,
чи цей кут тупий – взагалі,
який це кут, його точне значення.
Для того, щоб краще зрозуміти цю тему,
я рекомендую порозв’язувати більше задач.
Відкрийте підручник
або зверніться до вчителя.
Наш урок добіг до кінця, до побачення!